all right thank you so much I think it's
great that there are so many people here
to see a math talk on a Sunday morning
you know like I love math and I got into
math when I was very young and part of
why I got so excited about math was
through games different kinds of games
and different kinds of puzzles and
there's so much interesting math behind
puzzles and games and that's probably
the kind of thing that leads a lot of
you to be here now and when you get to
be a mathematician when you go through
college and graduate school and then
beyond that never really stops so one of
the things that I want to try to
convince you of is that there are a
bunch of really interesting questions
that mathematicians don't know how to
solve now that are easy to explain and
are related to puzzles and games you
might already know about so all right
I'm gonna need a bunch of volunteers
throughout throughout the talk and I
think I have my first wanna all right so
here's where we're gonna start we're
going to start with tic-tac-toe so let's
see how do I make this show up okay
does anybody not know how to play
tic-tac-toe all right so maybe some of
you don't know but you're not willing to
admit it so remember the goal is there's
two players X and O and you take turns
and the goal is to get something like
three in a row right so so here X is the
winner any questions good do you want to
play all right come on up so we're gonna
play twice once you go first once I'll
go first because there might be an
advantage to going first or going second
so do you want to go first here you go
all right
you can play the person sitting next to
you if you want to try to yeah alright
and it looks like a draw good game
rematch alright now I'll go first
I've thought a lot about this so I play
weird moves
haha all right I knew it
again good game I mean it's a little
unfair I spent a couple hours thinking
about this yesterday so I sort of have
an advantage so so 3x3 tic-tac-toe
probably if you play it enough
eventually you'll get to a point where
the game ends in a draw where there are
tricky things that oh can do so that
there's no way that X can force a
victory so so this is what I mean by
tic-tac-toe as a draw that there's no
strategy that X can follow to guarantee
victory so so what do we do with that
information you could just stop playing
which is probably what a lot of you have
done but another thing you could do that
mathematicians like to do is take a
problem that we understand and change it
around a little bit to get a new problem
so what if we played on a different
sized board like say five by five two
three four does that look like five by
five
all right I need a new volunteer yeah
sure
come on up Oh No
is this too high no you're good all
right what color do you want to be here
you go first or second all right
and you need five in a row to win no not
just three
I get so nervous like
ah
all right now I feel like there isn't
really anything left for me to try I
kind of think all the lines are blocked
good defense well played
and it looks like a draw good game well
played all right so did anybody has
anybody tried playing tic-tac-toe on a
larger board before yeah it's sort of
it's harder to win on a larger board and
there's one way to explain why it's
harder to win which goes like this so
here's your five by five board if you
want to win there's a three by three
board in the middle right here right in
the middle and if you want to win you
have to win on this board to write any
line except these four outer lines I
have so many colors so the so there's a
line here a line on here and a line here
but every other line goes through the
middle board and in fact every other
line consists of a line in the middle
board so if all has a way to draw in the
three by three game then one thing you
could try is just to try to draw in the
middle and then not to give away all the
squares on the outside so there's a way
to make this very precise we're all say
is five by five as a draw and what oh
should do is oat rise to draw in the
middle
and if X plays on the outside I should
just play next to X
so that's the idea so somehow is that a
question yeah yeah feel free to ask
questions throughout the top oh yeah
okay I don't know the answer for that
one but that's a great question one
thing you could do is just take a larger
board and say maybe you don't have to
get one two three four five six seven
eight row to win you only need four in a
row there's lots of ways around so what
you're suggesting is 19 by 19 where you
need five in a row to win I don't know
so people definitely study this but I'm
not sure for that one not off the top of
my head but but that's the kind of thing
we could figure out so okay so there's
it seems like what you need to get if
you have a five by five board and you
need five in a row it's harder to win
even than three in a row so here's an
exercise
here's homework for your Sunday
afternoon math lecture 4x4 is also a
draw and you can use the fact that you
can't win in a forum to show you can't
win in a 6x6 game it's the same idea
that inside a 6x6 grid there's a four by
four grid and if you can't win in the
four by four grid
you can't win in the bigger one as well
so so here we go so here's our first
result of the day math not you can take
any size bread let's say tic-tac-toe on
an N by n grid so okay what is n and is
just a number
like three by three four by four and so
on is a draw for any N greater than or
equal to three so if I draw you a ten by
ten board and say you need to get ten in
a row to win it's pretty easy to see
that you can't force a win there's no
strategy you can follow so so here's one
one thing I didn't mention two-by-two
tic-tac-toe so why not because you win
anything you do literally anything you
try X will win okay I'm X Oh has to
block and now any other square X is the
winner
so 2x2 is a win for X maybe not so
interesting okay so what's one way to
change this problem to make it
interesting again well instead of
playing with a grid you could play with
a three dimensional grid so who's seen
this before three by three by three
tic-tac-toe all right so let me just
explain so you can think of it as three
boards next to each other the high board
the middle board the low board and you
can win with a line inside of any of the
boards this is a winning line this is a
winning line but you can also have lines
that go between the boards so something
like like this is a line that goes from
the high board diagonally down to the
low board so this is a line and here's
one more let's say this is the hardest
one to see something like this one the
middle one and the lower rights this is
also a line any questions about sort of
the setup of the game you should try
this you should beat your friends
I need another volunteer all right come
on down
so again we're gonna play twice what
color do you want to be green red blue
blue it is do you want to go first or
second okay
so there's something different about the
3d version than the 2d version
all right good block good defense and
now I have to block this if I make a
mistake and we lose we can edit this out
on the video right okay but now I have
an attack here so it's this one this one
and this one yeah yeah that's all right
all right good game rematch and now you
go first
I always think of X going first I don't
know that's the second time you went
first with Oh as well oh yeah
okay I have to block this he's building
suspense now I'm in trouble though like
serious trouble oh well okay I'm gonna
block this one which you have the middle
it's like you're toying with me alright
good game well played
alright so okay so what's different
about three by three yeah so three by
three by three tic-tac-toe is a win for
X and the strategy so who can describe
what's a good strategy for the first
player in this game in the middle so the
middle square has so many lines going
through it let's see where did my board
go the middle square has so many lines
going through it that if you go in the
middle square you have this crushing
advantage and you can turn it into a
victory so here's something that's
harder to see that's a little surprising
so the idea is to play in the middle
place anywhere except the middle what
did the second player do play in the
middle and the second player can force a
victory from that point on so that's a
lot harder to check ou can force the
victory
so X always goes first okay so you can
ask these questions like why is the
middle so good how many lines go through
the middle and the answer is a lot way
more than any other square so here's one
way to think about it so how many lines
are there in regular tic-tac-toe that go
through the middle there's the two
diagonals and then these two so there
are four in here and then for any square
down here like this one there's a line
that goes through the middle and hit
something at the top so there's one line
through this point this point this point
there's another line this one this one
this one and so on you get nine more so
that's a little quick you should think
about the details of how you check
there's exactly 13 lines but the answer
is 13 and that's way more than any other
square okay so yeah question
ah but but there are four lines through
the middle square down here but those
don't go through the middle of the
middle the like core of the you know
cube so okay so now we're now we have a
problem again which is 3x3 tic-tac-toe
is a draw three by three by three is too
easy for X to win so we have to change
things even a little more to come up
with a game that's really interesting
that's in the boundary of like where
it's maybe you can win but it's really
hard to win okay so what can we do
so before I change out of 3x3 there's
one other weird thing going on here so
here's an exercise for you when you go
home so if you get tired of playing
three by three by three tic-tac-toe
because it's too easy to win what you
should do is try to draw so you and your
opponent X and O play together fill up
the board and try to make it so nobody
wins okay and the punchline is that
that's impossible so so it is completely
impossible there's way too many lines to
draw in three by three by three
tic-tac-toe and the idea is a set with
no lines like if you have 27 total
squares remember three times three times
three is 27 total squares if you wanted
to fill up the board X would have to
have 14 squares and up would have to
have 13 squares and it set with no lines
has to be small
so this is not easy to check this is a
homework problem I give to my college
students every year and you should think
about it but let's try to find an
interesting game I'm building suspense
through having too many pieces of paper
okay here we go how do i zoom
oh no I printed it too large I don't
think I can zoom out any farther for a
young person working in science I'm like
remarkably technically on a depth so I'm
sure that like all of you in the
audience could figure this out because
you were pretty much born with an iphone
in your hand but okay so here's the idea
four by four at six ecto four by four by
four I'm sorry you can't see the very
very bottom it's the same thing you need
four in a row to win so you can have
vertical lines like this one this one
this one this one the top-left corner of
every board so I need a volunteer and
here the game is really complicated so
we're gonna have to play with a kind of
time limit cuz these games can go on for
like five minutes ten minutes very
easily alright right up in the front
here we go were you practicing before
because I really don't want to lose okay
what do you think you want to go first
second so that should be an advantage so
the pressure is kind of off if I lose
oh okay
you can try this at home by the way
there's a whole bunch I printed out a
whole bunch of these boards you can take
them with you when you leave you can
wonder is it good to spread out your X's
and O's across the different boards or
do you want to kind of concentrate in
one I'm also just saying strategies out
loud to try to throw you off
wait what but here so so this line does
this one is one two three four would
make a line you need to you still have
to have it be like a straight line if
you think of it being a cube but all is
not lost where did you just go yeah all
right you can take this one back because
the rule isn't clear and you want to
block here instead all right so for
simplicity I'll take this one dramatic
moments right
I like that clear that you have to block
and attack because I don't need to think
I can just relax a little bit
all right I guess okay I see what you're
after oh you can't see the very bottom
road but i guarante Elling you it's very
exciting where'd you just go I think
okay like I'm in trouble oh I had this
great idea that I was gonna win right
there
we're down here the stress is getting to
me
who's winning right now am I losing am I
losing and I'm not realizing it yeah
it's really hot it's it's hard so this
is complicated enough that it's really
unclear who's winning at any given time
oh now I have this diagonal down here
alright so you can see how it goes if we
had more time I would definitely well
played
we could have a rematch okay so here's
the question who's supposed to win this
game right so yeah who wins this game so
so remember three by three by three is a
win for X but four by four is a draw so
it's conceivable either way then it
could be a winner it could be a draw so
there's a research paper about this from
1980
one thing that's pretty amazing is it's
one of the this involved a lot of
computer calculations so here's an
example here's a page from the paper you
can make a tree where here's the empty
board if X goes here here all the
different games that could result from
there and then here's another move down
very complicated but the punch line is
this is a win for X mm-hmm but it's very
hard for a human to learn the strategies
to always win there's a computer program
you can play online that will never lose
so I want to show you something from
this paper you can see that this is
really complicated there's so many
squares that there's so many different
possible games that it's really hard to
check them all by hand so this paper is
by patashnik and college mints can you
see that is that a good size okay so
I'll read it I'm deeply indebted to SC
Eisenstaedt in the Yale computer science
department for allowing me to complete
this project at commercial rates $0.10
per kilowatt and I'm imagining that the
young people in the audience have no
idea what that means but some small
amount of computer time by today's
standards this project would
cost me about fifty million dollars so I
think that's really cool that back in
1980 you had to sign up theater that a
share in the computer science department
and he writes elsewhere in the article
that he got a friend of his to let him
run his computer programs checking all
these configurations overnight late at
night for free maybe it had to pay for
it
4x4 tic-tac-toe would have been worth 50
million dollars so there you go so if
anybody has 50 plus million dollars to
kill to to waste to spend
I shouldn't say waste here's the first
unsolved problem for the talk so no one
knows is five by five by five a win or a
draw a win for X or a draw so this is an
unsolved problem so if you could solve
this which would definitely involve a
lot of computer calculation that would
be awesome
so here's the hints everyone thinks I
mean everyone not everyone thinks about
this but it's probably a draw
okay so I want to give you some other
tic-tac-toe type problems just from
people have done computer experiments
sort of using the same strategies that
lead to a win for the four by four by
four case and those strategies don't
work so something there would need to be
some other way to win yeah so so here's
another way to think about it and this
is how you might want to think about it
if you were a computer so we have a
three by three grid and what we're going
to do is assign every square a pair of
numbers
so let's say a and B where a says which
column you're in and B says which row so
here will be our columns 0 1 & 2 and
here are our rows 0 1 & 2 so what is
this square yeah you can just shout it
out so I heard the right thing so this
is 2 that's which column were in and 1
so this is 2 1 okay so what is the line
so if you describe it in this way what
is a line well it's three points a 1 B 1
a 2 B 2 a 3 B 3 we're either all the AIS
are equal and the BI 0 0 1 & 2 that's a
right like here's 2 0 to 1 to 2 or all B
eyes are equal you have the 3 points 0 0
1 1 2 2 or there's one other possibility
what's the last one yeah all right yeah
exactly that's the diagonal line that
goes this way to 0 1 1 0 2 so you can
describe your lines in terms of these
sets of numbers okay so what does that
let us do once we think about it like
this so now I can't draw a board for you
anymore but you can think what would
tic-tac-toe look like in 4 dimensions so
what that would be is your points are
given by 4 numbers a1 b1 c1
d one where each is zero one or two and
your lines are described in a similar
way you can see what a vertical line
would have to be and I'll say there
that's an exercise for you to figure out
exactly what the set of lines should be
okay so there's no reason why we only
have to do this with three now we can
think what about four by four by four by
four what do you think is that a win or
a draw you don't really have to think
about it in terms of space to guess the
right answer so like how many people
think it's a win how many people think
it's a draw
how many voting at all but you're not
taking a stand there we go
so so it is a win so this is a win and
here's the way to think about it three
by three is a draw but three by three by
three is a win sorry is a win the idea
is in higher dimensions
it's easier to win
okay so now I'm going to introduce a
little bit of notation that maybe will
be unfamiliar to people but instead of
saying like five by five by five we
could write this as five and brackets
this tells you how many rows how many
squares in a row and then a three up top
and this tells you how many dimensions
okay so so here what does this mean n to
the K this means n squares in a row n by
n by N by n K times so so here's two
more unsolved problems that people would
be really interested in if you could
solve so part of why I want to mention
all these unsolved math problems is that
if one of you goes on and solves one of
these problems then because I mentioned
it to you I feel like I get to take a
little bit of the credit like five
something like that so I think that's
how it works
okay so it's harder to yeah so when you
go from three by three to four by four
it's harder to win on four by four than
it is on three by three so the idea is
that it's harder to win when n goes up
so here's the real way of saying it if
the end to the K or remember n by n by n
by N by n K times game is a draw then
the n plus 1 to the k game is a draw so
one way to think about it is going if
three by three is a draw then four by
four should also be a draw but it's not
obvious at all so I'll tell you here's
what we know
we think that this is true everyone
thinks that this is true we know that if
and to the K is a draw then if you make
the size of the grid to larger in every
direction and plus two to the K is a
draw and the argument here is what I
showed you before that like inside a
five by five grid there's a three by
three grid in the middle wait on the
middle board you shouldn't be able to
win on the bigger board that contains it
in the middle but that argument doesn't
quite work when this two is a one so
there's one problem
and here's another it's easier to win in
higher dimensions so if the n to the K a
game is a win then the end to the k plus
one game is a win so three by three by
three is a win three by three by three
by three did I say at the right number
of times four times should also be a win
and basically any strategy you try will
work that as you go like with more
numbers more dimensions it should be
easier to win and we don't know how to
prove this either so I'll transition
from tic-tac-toe to something else after
saying one more thing so here's one more
sort of place where
are sort of difficult modern mathematics
meets these puzzles and games that we've
known about for a long time oh ok so
here's one question here's sort of a
boundary question is five by five by
five by five a win for X the answer is
probably yes
so remember five by five by five we
don't know it's probably a draw and you
go up one more dimension it's probably a
win but we don't know interestingly this
might be easier to prove than proving
five by five by five is a draw because
all you have to do is show that there is
one strategy where X can force a victory
you don't have to consider all possible
strategies okay
so here's one more transition thing so
remember three by three by three
Tanna and in a draw it's just impossible
to fill up the board so that there's no
lines if there's fourteen x's and
thirteen OS so there's this difficult
modern mathematical result called the
Hales Jewett theorem so I'll mention the
name in case you want to look it up I
don't want to explain exactly what it
says but one thing it says is a set with
too many points can't have to have a
line
so what does that have to do with
tic-tac-toe so what that means is okay
here's our next mathematical theorem
difficult mathematical fact for every n
remember this is the number of squares
in a row there is a K remember this is
the number of dimensions so that the N
by n by n by N by n K times game cannot
end in a draw so this is pretty this is
amazing this is kind of hard to prove so
here's the exercise so for N equals 3
remember for N equals 3 I said K equals
3 you can't possibly have a draw so what
is this number
for N equals 4 so four by four by fourth
Tec Tec so there's no winning strategy
but it's definitely possible to fill up
the board so there's no winning line but
what about one four by four by four by
four or four by four by four by four by
four or whatever so these questions are
the kinds of things that actually come
up in other areas of mathematics and
people are really like into ok any
questions about tic-tac-toe stuff at
this point I'm going to transition a
little bit yes
Yeah right that's a good question so
actually that's such a good question
that I kind of feel like did I tell you
to ask that beforehand so so here's a
four by four by four board here's
another one here's another one here's
another one one way to think of four
dimensions is take four 3-dimensional
boards and put them next to each other
and assign each one a color and say like
this is the red board here's the blue
board the green and the brown all the
eights colors start with E and the gray
silver I don't know
Oh yellow and you can say okay a line
can be something where you have the same
square in all four different colored
boards like now this is a line because
you have the top left square in every
one of the four boards next to each
other so that's my best piece of advice
about how to picture four dimensions I
don't really have a good suggestion for
five so yeah that's a great question
like how would you actually play this
game if you tried to play this game
there's so many squares that it might
take you like half an hour an hour
something like that so yeah I think
someone should try it probably not me
but two of you should play okay so I
want to change a little bit and talk
about another game maybe it doesn't seem
that way so how many people have seen
set before this card game
all right cool so typical works so
there's a so each card has four
attributes has four properties or yeah
I'll say properties so we have the
number of symbols which is going to be
one two or three we have the color which
is going to be red I always have to
remember purple or green here you go oh
it's too bright red purple green we have
the shading which is going to be clear I
don't have a clear one up here right now
solid or stripes and then we have the
shape and the shape is going to be a
diamond an oval or the squiggly s thing
which I can't draw at all I'll try to
find you one
maybe if I look at it I can do it
I was always better in math class in an
art class so okay so that's the setup
and there's exactly one card for each
combination for each combination so how
many cards are there well there are
three choices for the symbol and then
there's three choices for the color and
then there's three choices for the
shading and finally three choices for
the shape so there's three times three
times three times three 81 total cards
okay so the goal of the game is U is a
collection of cards wherein each
property
they're either all the same or all
different ah alright does that make
sense so after you okay here we go
so maybe the color isn't so clear this
one's red these are purple and
everything else is green so there are a
lot of sets here so we can give me an
example of a set yeah sure
this one
yeah exactly so this is a set because
there are four properties color and in
color they're all the same the number of
symbols and the number of symbols is all
different
the shading they're all striped and then
the shape they're all this squiggly
thing yeah yeah yeah so this was harder
to see so they all have a different
number of symbols they're all different
colors they're all different shapes so
that's also a set so the way that you
play is you deal out a bunch of cards 12
cards usually and the players will look
resets and if you see one you say set
and then you take those three cards and
then you replace them so let's see I'm
not gonna be able to find a set on the
fly but you might say if this was the
start of the game say set and you would
take the top three and then you would
replace them so that's the goal is to
get as many sets as possible when you go
through the deck one time so it's I like
this game a lot cuz I think this is very
fun there are all sorts of great math
questions you could ask here like how
many total sets are there or why do we
play with twelve if you deal out twelve
cards how likely is it that you have at
least one set questions like that so one
thing I want to do okay so I also
printed out some some other things for
you to look at one is a puzzle so you
can go to actually The New York Times
has a set puzzle every day so they put
up a puzzle and they say can you find
all the sets in this collection of cards
so here there are exactly five so I
printed out some copies of this so you
can look at that on your way out
or you could do harder things like say
how many sets are there here I'll come
back to that in a second this is an
interesting configuration because it's
kind of like a magic square every one of
the lines is a set and in fact there are
these extra lines that go like here here
and here
where you're allowed to wraparound
that's a diagonal line where you kind of
go here here and then the next diagonal
square would be here but it's not there
so you go back here that's a set this is
a set everything inside is a set so you
can ask what's going on that these kinds
of things exist so okay so I guess the
the question I want to ask now is why
did I bring this up so what does this
have to do with lines well what we're
gonna do is in each property we'll
assign each possibility
a number so let's say I'll write in a
different color to make this better then
for each property will just say 0 1 & 2
so this this looks bad because now if
you have three symbols you get a two if
you have one symbol you get a 0 red will
be color 0 purple is color 1 green is
color 2 0 1 2 0 1 2 so now what is a
card so then a card is a collection of 4
numbers a1 b1 c1 d1 where each is 0 1 or
2 so now this should look a lot more
like how I was describing tic-tac-toe at
the end of the tic-tac-toe discussion
right so okay so what is this card what
are the numbers for this red stripy oval
two thing so what's the first yeah what
does it get is the first number at 1 0
to 1 so you can do that for any set of
cards for any card you can assign it a
number and now the punchline is what is
a set well it's three cards so it's
three numbers a1 b1 c1 d1 a 2 B 2 C 2 D
2 a 3 B 3 C 3 D 3 where for each letter
what needs to be true so what happens so
if they all have the same number of
symbols like if they all have one symbol
then the A's are just zero zero zero and
if they all have a different number of
zeros sorry a different number of
symbols then the A's one of them is zero
one of them is one and one of them is
two so for each letter there either all
the same or all different Oh different
so that's the game so you could just
take away the cards and say well we
don't want to have these cards with
these symbols anymore let's just play
with sets of four numbers if you do that
it's way less fun don't do that I'm
actually better at that version of the
game than the one with the symbols Oh No
this is dramatic pause I've never been
so good at being able to like see the
different aha
alright there we go being able to see
the different patterns so so okay what
kind of math is this related to so I
won't say this in detail but one thing
you could do is you add up the ace a 1
plus a 2 plus a 3 if these three cards
are a set what could this possibly add
up to yeah right so it could be zero if
all of them are zero it could be three
if they're all ones or if they're zero
one and two in some order Bert could be
six if they're all twos but that's it if
they're not a set then other things
could happen if they're not a set
there's some property where the four not
where the three numbers add up to
something else then it's zero one or two
and it adds up to three yeah right so
there's only these three possibilities
so I'll just say that this thing about
cards and lines is related to the
geometry of this weird space of the
space called
at three to the fourth so I won't
explain exactly what that means but the
three is the number of possibilities for
each property
and the four is the number of properties
okay does that make sense question yeah
all right so here's our next difficult
mathematical result this is not easy to
prove at all this first part is not so
bad there is a collection of 20 cards
with no set so this isn't so hard to
prove because what would you need to do
to show that this was true you just have
to find 20 cards that have this property
and okay
I've now spoiled this puzzle here it is
so there are no sets among this
collection of 20 cards which is really
unusual so you can really think about it
and check but you can show there are no
sets in here and that's the best you can
do or the worst you can do depending on
what your goal is in any collection of
21 cards any of 21 cards there is at
least one set
so one way to think about this is this
collection of 20 cards with no sets is a
special collection of 20 points in this
space with no line so the very last
thing I'll say I'll stop right now but
there's this other question so these
problems were all about you wanted to
put down a lot of points and not have
any lines so you can do the opposite
you could ask if you place n points how
many lines can you have that do contain
3 points
so this question isn't easy so for
example you can see this one down here
this is the best you can do with nine
points the first thing you might try is
to just put your points in like a
tic-tac-toe configuration because now
any tic-tac-toe line contain three
points so this gives eight and it turns
out if you squeeze these two points in a
little bit you pick up one extra line so
we know the answer four and up to 14 and
N equals 16 that's it
so this one is very closely related this
is called the orchard planting problem
obviously that's supposed to be Jo so
there thank you so the very last thing
I'll do is I'll explain why it's called
the orchard planting problem here we go
so here's the problem explained in a
poem fain would I plant a Grove in rows
but how must i its form compose with
three trees in each row to have as many
row rows as trees now tell me artists
mathematicians really if you please tis
all I want to know so so the question is
how do you place endpoints so that the
number of lines with exactly three trees
in it is at least the number of points
you put down so when you have eight you
can't do it when you have seven you
can't do it you can only start to do it
at nine when now you have these ten rows
of three so I'll stop there I'd be happy
to stick around and answer any questions
you have I hope that you go home and
think about some of these things and
please let me know if you solve any of
the unsolved problems
you